Selena Gomez honored with the  chart-topper award at Billboard women in  music oh this is overwhelming as she  clears up the rumors  so you weren't afraid to speak up when  people were saying we didn't thing I  have a Victoria's Secret what made you  decide to comment on that yeah I did  think I fit in trouble about my gobbets  I just felt like you know for me I am in  a place where it is my my right to have  an opinion and to say something and  defend myself because I'm always kind  I'm always nice and every now and then I  deserve to say what I feel all the fans  want to know can we set the record  straight Niall are you guys dated no I  love them I always have these amazing